yeah let's say john yeah very windy uh
maybe a little bit of a break right now
but don't get used to that
maybe get used to temperatures down a
couple of degrees but that too is not
going to last sherry's off today your
most accurate weather now forecast right
now
live view from our camera on top of the
strat looking to the north a little bit
of a bumpy ride you recognize the circa
there and the fancy lights there on city
hall let's check out the official
temperature
we actually have dropped now to 85 that
is three degrees cooler than 24 hours
ago
officially the wind is just out of the
east at six we'll check your
neighborhoods here in just
a second uh the red flag and fire
weather warnings remain up until later
tonight because you have that dangerous
combination of high wind
low humidity and hot temperatures we
will see some clouds creeping up today
we'll talk more about that
but hour by hour we'll be back in the
upper 80s by eight
winds still to 20 25 and increasing
throughout the day near 100 noon
above 100 for the high still above the
century mark at six this evening